how do we know where the diseases are in
the world okay so you have a Zika
outbreak right the question is how does
scientists know that that might happen
how would they predict can we do weather
forecasting and that kind of forecasting
but for diseases instead of weather the
hard part is that technically how do you
solve that problem he drilled that big
important question down to this very
simple question is can we use a mosquito
as a sensor you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using in an era
of AI breakthroughs and other exciting
advances in computer science dr. ben
Zorn would like to remind us that behind
every great technical revolution is a
programming language as a principal
researcher and the co-director of the
rise or research and software
engineering group at Microsoft Research
dr. Soran has dedicated his life to
making sure the software that now
touches nearly everything in our lives
is easy accurate reliable and secure
today dr. Zorn tells us some great
stories about bugs and whales weren't
just against the dumb side of smart
objects talks about his group's attempt
to scale the Everest of software
security and makes a solid case that the
most important programming language in
the world today is the spreadsheet that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
so let's actually start by setting up
the framework for what we're going to
talk about today what exactly do the
London whale and a better mosquito trap
have in common so they seem very
different but in the end I think if you
think about the world that we're in now
software plays a key role in our lives
and everything we do and so the thing
that connects these is that they're
fundamental challenges big problems but
at the core of solving those problems is
the ability to use software to actually
attack the problem and make it better I
work in the ear field of programming
languages and we really think every day
we go to work thinking what do we do to
make software better if we make software
better than we can make all the things
that depend on software better yeah so
what about the London whale what was
that situation one of the things that's
important to understand is much of the
finance world runs on spreadsheets and
spreadsheets capture a lot of
interesting information information from
banks information from stocks the London
whale was one of these traders
at JP Morgan and he had a spreadsheet
and he was looking at how much
volatility there was in a particular
stock and the reason they called him the
London whale is because he would make
enormous purchases a billion dollars
hence whale yeah yeah the whale so so he
did this and unfortunately in the
spreadsheet he used there was a bug and
so he thought the volatility of a
particular stock was much lower than it
really was and so he bought it thinking
okay it's gonna stay stable when in fact
it's swung and it went way down and he
lost literally billions of dollars and
so this was a human making a decision
but the decision was basically based on
a spreadsheet and that's a fundamental
offer that's the fundamental thing that
links these together is the bug and the
software made him lose all this money
and then at all the consequences I mean
the company lost nine hundred billion
dollars in a lawsuit essentially because
of that right so what about mosquitoes
okay yeah so let me talk about that I
think one of the things I really really
enjoy about working Microsoft is the
ability for people to have a vision and
attack that vision with their heart and
soul and I had an incredible researcher
working with me his name is Ethan
Jackson and he wanted to solve an
important problem and it wasn't a
problem about you money or etc it was
really a much more
problem which is how do we know where
the diseases are in the world okay so
you have a Zika outbreak right the
question is how do scientists know that
that might happen how would they predict
and so in his mind is what can we do
weather forecasting and that kind of
forecasting but for diseases instead of
weather the hard part is it technically
how do you solve that problem he drilled
that big important question down to this
very simple question is can we use a
mosquito as a sensor so can you take a
mosquito and look at what it's eaten in
its meal that blood contains viruses and
the viruses will tell you what diseases
are present in the current environment
that took him on this incredible journey
where he met with you know disease
experts he met with insect biologists
you know mosquito experts he worked with
field biologists to understand what
their process was you know how do they
go now and find out where the mosquitoes
are what kinds of things are happening
mosquitoes but the thing he connected
you know you can think of this as
connecting the dots he connected
mosquitoes to the cloud so in particular
it's not just that you catch a mosquito
it's also that you have to figure out
what it's DNA and the blood that it ate
was and that requires you to do gene
sequencing and it requires to do it as
scale and so he built a trap the project
is called premonition the device that
they created was a very very specialized
mosquito trap and the idea is that when
you catch things in the trap you catch
these very pristine mosquitoes and then
you sequence their DNA and you send that
to the cloud and in the cloud you decide
what did this mosquito eat does it have
Zika did the animal that bit heavy boa
and with those answers you can then say
well in this region we caught a mosquito
that has Zika or we caught a mosquito
the head of all and in the process of
surd asking this question and finding
answers he had to explore all kinds of
interesting problems in fact he
revolutionized the ability of field
biologists to collect data about
mosquitoes this new trap it tells you
things like when this mosquito was
caught so now they can understand over
the period of a day and when certain
types of species of mosquitoes come out
he knows the temperature he knows the
sort of environmental conditions around
the behavior of the mosquitoes which
they never measured another thing he did
basically the mosquito trap leverages
machine learning so the trap itself is
five pounds it has 64 individual cells
each one has a door okay and if it
mosquito flies in the trap can decide
whether or not to close the door so it
can say if that's a house fly I'm not
interested you know don't close the door
but if a mosquito flies in he can then
figure out using machine learning that
insect was the type of mosquito he
wanted and he can catch it this is like
so amazing it's too bad it's a podcast
cuz no one can see my face right now
well and let me just say this is not
just some person in a lab having cool
ideas one of the things about this
project is it's an incredible
collaboration across Microsoft Research
so we worked with people in the hardware
group he worked with people doing gene
sequencing actually there's people at
Microsoft Research that you know that
have expertise in doing it fast right
which you absolutely need to do so this
was a collaboration within the lab but
it was also externally because we don't
have people that are insect specialists
right or you know why 'allah gee
specialist was his specialty but so
amazing and his specialty is actually on
programming language formal methods so
he has this vision he built this thing
he executed on it it was an end-to-end
solution and it showed that you know you
can aspire to these kind of high-impact
capabilities and we have this kind of
environment here to really support that
I'm still thinking about how they could
tell what the mosquito had for lunch
because I mean it used to be just you
can spill mustard on your tie you could
tell what you what you had for lunch
check you ate a hot dog
[Music]
when people get excited about going into
computer science today but I think maybe
this will be my career they're often
attracted by the kind of buzzy hot
things like machine learning deep
learning AI whatever
what role does programming languages
play in that and why does somebody think
hey I'm gonna go into research mmm-hmm
because your organization is called rise
research in engineering so yeah so
that's a great question and it is true
that in the end what we do is we build
the things on which people build
incredible solutions yes we work on
software we work on making it easier to
build software making it easier to make
the software correct make it perform
well but I think too the way to think
about it is almost all the big
technological revolutions have had with
them accompanied a programming language
so if you go back to the late 70s you
know the advent of pcs one of the things
that really sold in the PC market was
spreadsheets yeah and it transformed the
financial industry you know we talked
about but those spreadsheets really
redefined how business people thought
about their business how they thought
about the future how they planned and
did the trends and so I think at the
core of programming languages this
ability to capture something that people
want to do so for example C++ was
fundamental in the growth object
learning programming right it was a way
to make it so that everyone that wanted
to do our gem program it could go to C++
there were mechanisms in there there was
sort of frameworks that were built on
top and they could start getting their
job done and the same thing with Java if
you want to do something on the web you
know Java was the language one of the
reasons you know that these things are
successful is because lots and lots of
people start programming on them right
away because it opens up a new frontier
for new developers for new business
opportunities and even lay people I mean
WordPress things you can go into the
HTML and that's right yes absolutely
markdown the ability to combine the
presentation and again with computation
you can embed JavaScript into a web
pages
yeah JavaScript again a transformative
technology really enabled the whole web
2.0 you know the sort of the ability to
do apps embedded in browsers and the
other one you know this is one that
doesn't I think get nearly enough credit
Visual Basic transformed the PC industry
in the sense that it
again easy for people who didn't have
the deep programming skills to put
together applications in verticals and
sell them and make a lot of money you
know because there was a need for those
things and the tooling that sort of the
language and the programming environment
made it easy for people to do that
that's so interesting let's talk about
the spreadsheet again because this is
one of your things that I think is super
interesting and it kind of goes was a
question I asked you about in an era of
AI infatuation the spreadsheet is
decidedly kind of unsexy languages in
programming language that of impact and
I have to say there are hundreds of
millions of spreadsheet users so by
numbers spreadsheets actually the most
important programming language in the
world and most people don't think of it
as a programming language but in the
essence of bread cheese you're combining
data and code because you're computing
on that data and presentation because
you want to see the result you want to
see the chart you're sees the table etc
so the spreadsheets are brilliant in
that it's very concrete it's not like
there's this abstract program and then
you feed it some data with a spreadsheet
you have the data right there and you
have the computing right there so that's
why it's so accessible but in the end it
is a program and as such you have bugs
you know which is one of the reasons
that say the London whale happened but I
think it's important to understand that
spreadsheets because they're so
successful are really a mechanism for
people who have questions about data and
more and more people want to answer
questions about data I mean it's like if
I have personal data you know about my
health I'd like to be able to ask
questions I don't want have to go to
somebody to write a program to answer my
question I'd like to ask that question
myself well put it in a spreadsheet if
you want to figure out can I retire now
right you know you put your data into a
spreadsheet
[Music]
this brings up it's like a host of
questions not the least of which is the
Internet of Things where you have all of
these independently Pro I mean so let's
say Microsoft is doing software and they
do tests and verify it and me you know
I'm guessing that's not the case in a
lot of things that are out there so I'll
talk a little bit about sort of the
Internet of Things you know one of the
things I've had incredible fortune I'm a
member of the CCC which is the computer
community consortium and this is part of
the CRA which is an organization that
represents computer science research to
the federal government the CCC is the
part of the CRA that actually is tasked
with thinking about the future thinking
about trends in computer science and the
part of the CCC that I've been most
active with is called the test force on
intelligent infrastructure and it looks
at this question of if we embed
computing into infrastructure or into
say the Internet of Things how does that
change the world and how do we think
about that that world and it goes to
what I said I was talking about before
about how every company now to get an
advantage instead of saying ok we're
gonna make our toaster better like
mechanically now it's like how can we
use software to make our toaster better
that's a mark toaster a smart does and
you think about you know for example you
know there's your doorbell there's ring
it's a big company now and they sell you
a smart doorbell it'll show you video of
who's at the door
you buy a Tesla well Tesla is a ton of
software you're really buying software
right Tesla sells you software upgrades
and they've sell that to you so that's
you know they basically converted
selling a car into selling software
right yeah the internet thinks it's
amazing though and it kind of goes crazy
you know so for example there's a smart
fork so if you look online there's a
smart fork and it's like wow you know
but the fork has a processor in it and
it counts how many times you lift it so
you base oh I need this fork so so
here's the thing is that you know smart
objects is smart Internet of Things
they're relatively cheap you know
nobody's gonna pay $1,000 for a smart
fork right and they've got to get to
market fast usually they're built on a
software stack which is open source but
the biggest problem is the level of
scrutiny that people pay attention to
with these things
are they secure what levels of care are
made in creating that software
moreover who's the fork talking to right
I mean are they saying hey Ben's
password is right so here's the problem
is that that that for be cut by
definition because it counts it probably
talks to some server on the Internet and
then I look at my wrist band and say oh
you've lifted that fork a hundred times
I mean yeah somebody's talking right
right so these things by definition are
connected because they you know they
wouldn't be smart if they were just by
themselves and you don't necessarily
know what software is running on them
and you don't necessarily know if
somebody's compromised that software so
for example yeah I don't really want to
have to worry if my if my fork is trying
to steal my internet and my wireless
password we're letting people know
you're not home that's right yeah or is
my yeah this is fork talking to the
doorbell I mean we didn't used to have
to think is my fork you know trying to
see my password but now we do because if
you buy that smart fork there is a
possibility and we are in a transition
with the Internet of Things where
there's sort of two classes right now of
quality and software there's certified
software like aircraft software you know
on it better line it is it is carefully
checked right so you're pretty confident
there but then everything else there's
no checking right there's no level of
certification in one things that I'm
doing with the CCC is understanding what
at the federal level what are the right
things for the federal government to be
doing in the space and in fact they are
actively working one of the models
they're looking at is using an
underwriters lab kind of model yeah so
that instead of saying underwriters lab
says you know this electric appliance
won't short-circuit and cause a fire
they're basically saying well this
device has reached some level of quality
which is better than just nothing does
that include security though yeah I mean
well it goes to questions about best
practices and their fundamental
questions like how do you update like
let's say you have a device and then
it's got a bug you know we know about
Windows Update we know that you know we
see PC updates frequently but how many
people update therefore I have never
updated my fork and and so the question
is like that's a problem because if
there is a security vulnerability and
you don't update it then your fork is
vulnerable get a fork patch exactly and
in fact this is not just a hypothetical
it happened about a year ago was people
have bought video cameras on the web and
it turned out that a hacker figured out
that many of the passwords on these
video cameras could be guessed so it
turns out they actually a hacked about a
hundred thousand or more of these
cameras okay so first of all if you have
a web camera and somebody's hacked into
it how would you even know so that's the
first problem for us so much I don't
know but the second problem is the
person who hacked this leverage all of
these a hundred thousand or more
machines to do a distributed
denial-of-service attack what that means
is that you have these cameras all send
packets to a particular website to make
it so that no one else could access it
and with a hundred thousand things you
can really shut things down and this was
a problem last year you know one of the
things that happens with the Internet of
Things you know with this emerging
presence of lots of devices without
security you know or with less
understand about how the security works
is that you can have these emerging
attacks based on large numbers of
devices the scenarios you've painted are
common in that people click agree on an
app for convenience right sure I don't
even know what they're right yeah so
there's two kinds of problems one is a
problem where there's a bug in the
software and somebody exploits that bug
it's doing things that was never
intended there's another problem which
is the software itself say an app on a
phone has privileges that it doesn't
really need when it says here's ten
things I'm gonna do if you know if you
want to use me how do you know what
things it really means not only that
it's a binary option I either don't say
yes or no could I do five of those right
so so I think the good news here is that
there is an evolving understanding of
how to enable like for example one of
the strategies is you say look I'm not
gonna say that you can do it when you
need it you ask me like what I'm about
to use something and it says I need to
use your camera right now then you say
yes cuz you're you know you're taking a
picture you understand which I've done
yeah can I access your photos okay cuz I
want to edit that photo exactly so I
think there is hope there in the sense
that the understanding of how people
interact with software how you can make
software more understandable you know is
evolving one of the things that you
could say it's a success story in the
sense that people are using these things
for so many different activities you
know so many apps on the phone so
apps on the computer the fact that
people want to use software for all
these purposes and that we have to
understand what that means and how to
control that more so if I get a smart
fork and I decide I want to upgrade it
and they say we don't support that
anymore are we just well no this is a
real concern and I I would basically say
and in fact you know the FBI provided a
public service announcement saying look
if you have Internet of Things devices
then you should put it on a separate
network so this is one of the things
they're telling people it's like have in
your home now have your network which is
like your computers and all your stuff
that you're using that you really need
and then everything else put on a
separate network and this is I
understand and it is a concern people
are Technopolis in a good way but I
think sort of analogy of the Wild West
is right now we're just seeing what all
the problems that can emerge over time I
think you know for example wireless
routers might actually have these two
networks sort of automatically you know
configured in such a way in fact even
now I think why routers will give you
guest networks but you have to know to
use them and you have to understand you
know the configurations listen you need
to be wider in this so let me talk a
little bit about a strategy we can go
toward that so there's a project in the
group it's called Everest which group in
my group rise up and what they're trying
to do is think about not just writing
software but writing software so that
it's fully verified so what does that
mean actually it fully is too strong a
word but verified for important
properties and so what does that mean so
in particular what they've taken on is
there's a communication infrastructure
that connects of web browser and a
server it's called HTTP you might have
seen it it's sort of yeah and I think
it's secure when I go there right you
get a lock that says you know the
communication between your client and
the server is encrypted
it's secure you know you can get you can
send your bank account numbers or your
your credit card numbers and no one
who's listening and can understand that
so that HTTPS is actually a lot of
software it's there's an implementation
of it in the open source called open SSL
and it's used widely in fact a couple
years ago there was a major problem with
open SSL called heartbleed which made
the news because you know it turned out
that people could look
on your computers through this
heartbleed bug and this was a problem
with open SSL was it a bug or a hack it
was a bug in the software that then
seemed like to figure it out how to
exploit exactly and it was unclear how
widely exploited it was because it's
very hard to tell if people have been
using it anyway so open SSL is an
implementation and what the Everest team
said was look we're gonna build an
equivalent version of open SSL but we're
gonna make our version verified for the
important properties like the
cryptographic properties okay now this
is using program verification on a scale
that's never been attempted before
because these communication protocols
have many layers they include many
different encryption algorithms and the
properties you need to prove include
things like well you can't have a memory
safety violation which is the kind of
thing that heartbleed exploited that's a
very basic property but the higher-level
properties are if if two people are
talking and you know each end of the
line we're gonna guarantee with this
proof that there's no way that an
attacker can listen in it doesn't matter
how you know how the attacker tries
they're not going to be able to hack the
software to decrypt these messages
that's a very challenging problem
because it's a combination of proofs
essentially looking at each line of code
and saying you know what are the
possible ways that this can go wrong but
at a scale of thousands and thousands of
lines of code and the ability to prove
things about thousands of lines of code
is actually very difficult if you think
about these proofs we're talking about
literally hundreds of thousands of
formulas all connected together to form
the proof and then saying yes that you
know we can prove that that set of
formulas actually is satisfiable it says
you know there is a way that this could
be true and that no human would be
capable adding this so that Everest is
one of the projects that's come out of
rice that's right yeah so it's a rice is
a group I co manage it with Tomball
research and software engineering is a
group of researchers and developers we
collaborate on a number of different
kinds of projects across a spectrum so
we work on software engineering problems
like how do we build software more
effectively how do we deploy software
more effectively how do we help
developers understand where the problems
in the code are or are what problems you
know they should may
do a code review for so that's one that
in the spectrum on the other end of the
spectrum is we think about the formal
foundations of software so we're trying
to ask questions like what does the
software mean exactly how do we
translate essentially a program into
math and then use what we know about
math to prove what that program is going
to do or not do and unless you get that
kind of level of understanding we're
gonna be in a world where we do have
these bugs you know we do run into
problems where somebody deploy software
and things like open SSL which is widely
deployed and it's a problem with devices
because once it gets deployed on 'save
routers all of a sudden it's very hard
to update right it's very hard to fix
the bug so what you really would like to
do instead is verify the software before
you deploy it right and that
verification requires a deep
understanding of what the software is
how to reason about how to prove things
about it and the tools and one of the
key things about Everest is it builds on
top of a tool called c3 which is a very
very powerful tool used not just by
people in my group but by people all
over the world you know thousands of
citations to the work where if you have
a problem that you can specify as a
sequence of constraints like an X is
greater than the 3y is greater than 2x
plus y is less than 53 it will actually
take that and then solve it it'll say
here's here's a value for x and y that
will make this thing true or if it's not
possible to make it true it will say
it's not satisfiable yeah so z3 is a
mechanism on which people build that
helps people think about complexity of
logic at a scale that you know is
unprecedented yeah you're here doing
this my mind is going into all the other
things that I have and I know how
expensive it is to test software so is
anything this isn't even a question I
had on my list but you've just prompted
me to think of all these developers out
there doing Smart Objects mm-hmm with
their own code and probably just
shipping sure are you guys doing
anything to make it less expensive or
more easy right I think what you see in
the world of software is people want to
reuse code they don't want to write
their code from scratch right so a great
example is cryptography algorithms right
when you think about cryptography
algorithms it's very hard to write that
code it's actually in performance it's
critical because it
and decryption you know is something
that you you don't really want to do but
you have to and so it's got to be fast
but the problem is that if everyone had
to write their own cryptography
algorithm most of them are probably
wrong because it's very very you know it
really is you have to be super smart to
get it right so what you'd rather do is
actually do it once and then verify it
and then use the verified thing and
everybody could use that verified thing
I mean one of the nice things about open
source is once it's available there's no
barrier so what we're trying to do with
Everest actually Everest is an open
source project we're trying to build
bigger and bigger components that people
can use and reuse instead of having to
try to do themselves
[Music]
what are the unique challenges for
software engineers now that maybe they
didn't face 30 or 40 years ago great
question you think about software
developer and say 1990 over 1995 where
you know they're thinking about a
building a desktop app like it's on the
desktop doesn't talk to anything you
know it's the UI it's you know maybe in
the logic etc but you think about the
developers life now and how totally
different it is and one of the key
things is you're building a service
right you're not building something this
it's not somebody's desktop you know if
it crashes okay that one version goes
down but everyone else's is fine right
when you build a service it's running
24/7 it's got to always work and if it
crashes everyone all your customers all
of a sudden don't have something so the
developers life is much much more
complicated now but it's also I mean the
beauty of the service model is the kinds
of things that you can do you know with
a service it empowers you know software
dramatically so it's harder for the
developer you've got all these new
things to think about you know there's
the deployment process how do i you know
how do I sort of you know make sure that
as I deploy it to more more people that
it you know it's it still has the great
quality etc but I think at the core of
the the job is still you know is the
software right does it perform well you
know and is my customer happy I would
imagine that some one of your major
goals in Microsoft Research rise
absolutely I mean you know are the whole
investment we have you know I mentioned
we talk about software engineering so
that's the process of building software
talk about formal methods that's really
figuring out what the software should be
doing and making sure it's doing that
and I think another part is actually
helping developers one of the really
successful collaborations we've had in
MSR in my group is that we have a really
a talent individual Marc Maron who
worked on something called time travel
debugging okay okay go there a few words
about this so time travel debugging this
is a vision that developers have had for
years and years which is if there's a
bug if there's a crash or something
instead of like starting over and seeing
what happens I really just want to step
back one step
in time sir what what happened that got
me here technically that's a really hard
problem because to do that you have to
actually remember everything that
happened between when the program
started and when it crashed and so even
though this has been a vision for many
years actually giving it to developers
to use in a practical way has never
happened now this is before Marc Maron
and time travel debugging so Marc
basically said look in JavaScript which
is a very widely used language we can
build a mechanism inside the JavaScript
virtual machine that captures an enough
information efficiently enough that now
we can enable developers with that go
back button this is a collaboration so
this is Marc in research this was his
vision but he said look you know it's
not gonna just be enough to write a
paper I want to make sure that this is
actually in chakra which is the
Microsoft JavaScript virtual machine so
he went to the chakra team he talked in
them he sat with them and at this point
time travel debugging is now part of the
open source chakra release you know
that's really inspiring to know because
it feels like a common theme I'm hearing
is that people are talking to other
people seeing how can they bring in
expertise from other areas within
different groups even in the research
group right and no absolutely and one of
the things I think that's really
exciting is going with with especially
with the success of AI is it opens up
new collaborations you know interactions
with groups that we didn't used to
interact as much with partly because
these questions I mentioned but partly
because you know it's always exciting
and you know every time you have this
kind of shift in the way people think
about the complexity their new problems
they can solve new ways to solve it one
of the things that's really exciting
about the AI technology is it does
change what it takes to build these
models if you say well I need a
developer to write the code that's one
thing but if it's a I need labeled
examples you know to Train that's a
totally different set of skills are and
it changes you know who can do it and
how you do it and so every time these
changes happen it's a new cycle and we
get to do all these fun things again
right right
that's so interesting well listen let me
wrap up with asking because I'm really
interested about who comes here what do
you look for in somebody that you would
like to come here and work with you and
rise well I think there's a couple
things I think we look for people who
are broad thinkers that really you like
I said they go to the heart of the
problem one of the things we offer
Microsoft which is really different than
an academic experience is we have
incredible depth in the product teams so
you know the product teams are dealing
with real problems every day and sort of
thinking in terms of you know that's an
opportunity for for the people to come
here the researchers that come here
that's something that they just can't
get it in the academic world you know
you want people that embrace that that
basically look as broadly as possible as
sort of how they can impact you know the
world the company in the end like I said
we look for people to build stuff people
who want to think about solving problems
sharing solutions you know having people
use those solutions and get their hands
on those things and so the sort of the
the expansiveness the willingness to
work and learn across disciplines I mean
one of the things that we have is a huge
resource you know Microsoft Research it
has incredible depth you know compared
to almost any academic department in the
world if you're here and you don't step
across the hallway and start talking to
people doing things you know very
different than you that's just a missed
opportunity all right so I think those
are the kind of things that you know
resume when I look to hire people
obviously we have a lot of visibility in
the academic community for the things we
have done people come to us with an
understanding of the kind of expertise
and the kind of strategy we use to solve
important problems you know something
like project Everest is a great example
where security is incredibly important
you know it has an enormous visibility
it's an expedition which is a basically
a multi lab effort so it's not just
people and Rises people in Cambridge you
have Sherpas yeah so it's it's a team
effort but I think one of the things
about that is it reflects an
understanding this is such an important
problem you know and it's not just an
important problem for Microsoft an
important problem for the world and in
fact you know understanding how to do
this process and understanding what
tools are needed and you know what can
and can't be done you know is really
going to be very important for the whole
software you could system in and
ten years the fun thing is that you know
every day is a new day we get to have
really exciting collaborations it's a
dream job I mean it's one of those
things where working with the talented
people that I work with every day is the
best possible thing you can imagine and
Zorn
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Benson's and the
wide wild world of programming languages
visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]